[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue pour une émission qu'on a un petit
peu chamboulé bien sûr pour parler de la
disparition de l'immense charles
aznavour le chanteur est mort
aujourd'hui à 94 ans et on n'évoquera sa
mémoire tous ensemble on parlera aussi
des manuels macron qui étaient aux
antilles ce week-end s'est fait prendre
en photo avec deux jeunes gens dans une
pause on va dire pas très officiel c'est
impardonnable dit marine le pen
et vous qu'en pensez-vous vous nous le
dire et nous parlerons aussi d'une
proposition qui a été faite par la
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse était hier au grand
jury rtl le figaro lci
valérie pécresse est favorable à un
durcissement des peines à un doublement
même quand les actes de deux des
agressions ont lieu en banlieue
est ce vraiment une bonne idée vous ne
viendrez votre point de vue on parlera
de la dépendance c'est aujourd'hui la
journée internationale des personnes
âgées
c'est aussi l'occasion de se poser la
question prenons nous assez soin de nos
aînés
bonsoir caroline valentin merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes et céistes
collaboratrice du figaro vox vous avez
contribué à une france insoumise et une
france où mise par dont vous voyez c'est
une
c'était tout l'intérêt d'être et
pourtant c'est un livre je connais
puisque on a dû y consacrer à peu près
12 pages où les gars au magazine 60
jours et prédateurs voilà mais gégé
allemagne trop vite
vous avez aussi contribué un livre
publié aussi chez albin michel cette
année celui là le nouvel antisémitisme
bonsoir xavier couture bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller audiovisuel vous avez été pdg
de canal+ enfin vous avez un parcours
audiovisuel
j'ai fait deux trois choses voilà
important d'être avec delphine ernotte à
france télé et vous êtes un instrument
entre autres polémiste a refait le monde
l'émission de nos confrères t exactement
patrick peloux et là aussi bonsoir
docteur soit vous êtes médecin
urgentiste président de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france
ancien chroniqueur à charlie hebdo est
votre dernier livre l'instinct de vie a
été publié au cherche midi
et bonsoir alexandre ii vecchio cette
journaliste aux pages débats opinion du
figaro vous êtes en charge du figaro vox
vous avez signé l'un des sujets de
couverture du figaro magazine consacré
au philosophe françois xavier bellamy
est votre dernier livre les nouveaux
enfants du siècle a été publié aux
éditions du cerf
on commence bien sûr pas rendre hommage
à l'immense charles aznavour dont on a
appris la mort il ya il ya quelques
minutes
il avait 94 ans lui se serait bien vu
vivre encore un peu plus longtemps
écouté ce qu'ils disaient c'était chez
nos confrères de francs 5 pas plus tard
que vendredi dernier on a décidé avec ma
soeur qu'on n'avait pas sauvé son as et
écrit ses dérivés
elle n'a pas le droit de lâcher ça et
j'ai pas le roi david couture vous avez
une particularité sur ce plateau c'est
que vous avez connu charles aznavour
qu'elle quel souvenir en gardez vous je
lui ai connu parce que ayant longtemps
collaboré avec la grande chaîne tf1 nous
l'avons accueillie à de nombreuses
reprises dans des émissions de variétés
même dans des émissions d'information
garder un souvenir de charles aznavour
se serait d'abord ce serait très près ce
que présomptueux de ma part on en a tous
des milliers à la fois en tant que
amateurs de ses chansons en tant que fan
entre guillemets et peut-être pas aimé
ce mot et puis l'homme et est tout à
fait impressionnant parce que sa rigueur
la rigueur qu'il avait dans ses mots il
avait la même dans sa vie c'est à dire
que j'ai rarement vu un artiste dont
l'exigence sur lui même qui était
d'ailleurs une exigence qu'il exerçait
sur les autres étaient portés à ce point
là alors jamais ils avaient des formules
marié va mobiliser
je suis le moins mauvais des pierres
pianiste que j'ai eu il avait il avait
conscience de ses limites sur un certain
nombre de sujets il a été le pianiste
d'edith piaf à tout le monde sait ça il
a il a créé ensuite un certain nombre de
chansons pour d'autres avant de se
mettre lui-même à chanter alors qu'il
avait la conscience d'avoir une voix
particulière il était il est il ne
considérait pas qui était le plus grand
chanteur du monde et en même temps ça a
été évidemment un ambassadeur assez
curieux d'ailleurs parce qu'il était
d'abord l'ambassadeur
de l'arménie qui était son pays
d'origine et il a été un
il a été un merveilleux ambassadeurs de
la langue française la chanson française
des mots qu'il arrivait à trousser comme
dans cette chanson qui pour moi est
restée la chanson de mon enfance à peine
le petit bois de trousse chemise
il a fait une très grande forêt de trop
ce mot est franchement cet homme a été
probablement l'un des unes des figures
marquantes un géant enfin moi j'ai
presque honte de lui rendre hommage qui
suis-je pour pour jouer à ça mais c'est
vrai que nous sommes tous impressionnés
par la carrière le talent
l'exceptionnelle bonhomme qui a été
charles aznavour petit bonhomme qui
portait avec lui sa culture son ambition
son art vraiment je suis à la fois
triste et puis voilà on va dire que il
laissera une trace que peu ont réussi à
laisser de la chanson française
il aimait la télévision quand il venait
à tf1 que vous l'accueillez là bas
c'était un peu une figure imposée
plutôt oui enfin pour lui il faisait
partie des obligations de sa carrière et
je ne suis pas certain qu'il qui qu'il
aima beaucoup la télévision en tant que
tel je crois qu'il aimait bien un
certain nombre de gens de télévision je
ne prétends pas en faire partie il
aimait beaucoup de pouvoir interpréter
ses chansons dans un cadre quand on le
mettait à sa disposition qui était
suffisamment valorisant à la fois pour
sa musique et pour ses textes il
n'aimait pas beaucoup le la rupture de
temps le recteur temporel que la
télévision impose c'est à dire cette
espèce de deux grandes machines à zapper
qui n'était pas complètement sa culture
il aimait s'installer dans le temps
d'ailleurs il faisait des quand tu fais
et aricie talent c'était toujours sur
une durée assez longue
dans des salles importantes il avait un
lien avec direct avec le public même des
des publics très nombreux mais ils
établissaient un lien magique avec ce
public
je crois que la télévision qui est un
outil plus plus plus plus rapide un peu
un peu zappé ans et où on a une touche
pas vraiment le public n'était pas
complètement sa tasse de thé il était
d'une époque on aimait les salles de
spectacle on aimait cette rencontre avec
avec le public même sept enfants étaient
toujours très bien réglée moi j'ai
souvenir d'un concert de charles
aznavour au palais des congrès y en a eu
beaucoup
et il terminait toujours son concert par
cette chanson
verrons nous un jour ou l'autre et il
n'y avait pas de rappel après enfin on
savait que c'était terminé parce que
c'était organisé comme ça car une
valentin vous avez une chanson de
charles aznavour que vous avez personnel
ont rythmé pas que mon enfance
d'ailleurs ma vie d'adulte
mais la bohème ou emmenez moi au bout de
la terre que je chantais quand j'étais
un cabinet d'affaires à 3 heures du
matin je ne pouvais plus voilà donc mais
je veux qu'on peut pas parler c'est
difficile de parler de charles aznavour
en deux minutes
il avait 94 ans une vie tellement
incroyablement magnifique
je crois qu'on lui doit surtout beaucoup
d'admiration il a reçu d'ailleurs tous
les honneurs que son talent le faisait
méritée dans tous les pays du monde
voilà un homme qui a travaillé
collaborer avec fred astaire dit crosby
frank sinatra mais gérer jazz l'aesa
minnelli je me rappelle j'avais voulu
aller à un concert j'avais entendu qu'il
était un concert j'avais une vingtaine
d'années de sas étaient 5000 francs la
place à l'époque donc mais c'était un
concert caritatif et tout mais ces voix
là ç'a donné la dimension en fait
évidemment là s'étaient plaints archi
plein donc voilà c'est quelqu'un non à
qui on rend hommage et qui est un modèle
et il a touché cette génération cette
génération il est il était adoré d'un
public qui avait 70 ans ou 80 ans
lorsque il a commencé sa carrière de
chanteur et encore aujourd'hui et des
gamins de 20 ans de 25 ans après si
c'était ce poète incroyable donc ce sont
des vrais mancebo jeu j'ai fait le
calcul tendant voiture pour se défaire
cette génération de public dans ces eaux
là qui ont été touchés par ces textes
mais sid qui entre 9 et 13 ans m
voyez m à 0 patrick pleau c'est très
triste mais il savait lui-même
preuve en est ce qu'il a dit à france 5
il ya quelques jours il savait qu'il
était quand même dans un âge avancé et
la mort est inéluctable
maintenant moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour lui parce que c'est le music hall à
l'ancienne et qu'on aimait tant avec les
salles de spectacle avec ce show man
qu'il était avec sa carrière carrière
d'acteur taxi pour tobrouk
c'est lui avec ventura qui tiennent le
film s'était pas rien puis il a fait une
carrière d'acteur qui est tout à fait à
mon avis honorable et puis les chansons
moi c'est j'habite seul avec maman qui a
été la première chanson ce qu'on se
disait avant de débuter des missions sur
l'homosexualité et qui était quelque
chose de très porteur mais sam en fait
c'est marrant parce que ont fait quelque
part il est mort mais il existe encore
parce qu'on a la chance d'avoir les
disques de pouvoir réécouter de pouvoir
analyser encore ces paroles etc et
d'avoir des films sur ces concerts et là
ça interpelle sur sur l'avenir qu'il y à
du music hall à l'heure actuelle des
carrières des auteurs des compositeurs
il faut trouver il faut pas désespérer
en sont un pays qui adore la
désespérance mais faut pas désespérer il
faut chercher les nouveaux charles
aznavour quoi il ya beaucoup de
réactions très ému non bien sûr sur les
réseaux sociaux dominique qui nous dit
qu'il repose en paix merci à lui pour
cette très belle chanson evelyne au
revoir chars nous écouterons encore et
encore vos chansons sont un grand
monsieur nous quittent pour jeanne
heydari un monstre sacré pour laurence
car elle nous dit je pleure charme
t'aimons tous tu es ma fierté française
et arménienne
alexandre de vécu ou est-ce que ça vous
parle
charles naveau vous avez une chanson
préférée ou sait pas trop ce n'était pas
si c'est bien sûr ça me parle moi j'en
citerai trois la bohème parce que je
crois que c'est comme ça que tous les
hommes les bons
vivre au moins au moins quelques temps
d'ailleurs l'émission en écoutant
quelques menues voilà comme ils disent
qui a déjà été cité
c'était une chanson d'une modernité
incroyable effectivement qu'il parlait
pour la première fois de l'homosexualité
mais sans pathos et sans morale pas sûr
qu'on écrira de la même façon
aujourd'hui et enfin je me voyais déjà
parce que je crois qu'il a il assez ça
résume aussi toute sa vie et il a su en
quelques mots des pins de personnes le
feu sacré qui peut y avoir en chaque
artiste donc oui c'était ça quelqu'un
qui est qui et qui s'avère en quelques
mots touché à la vérité des êtres
humains charles aznavour et et voilà
c'est c'est un grand poète et après
c'est aussi un destin français il est né
chan hourvari nagase nav orient et il
est devenu l'ambassadeur de notre
culture de notre langue de la france
tout simplement et ça aussi c'est une
forme de success stories presque presque
à l'américaine qu'on devrait compte
devrait valoriser
il le disait d'ailleurs en février 2013
il déclarait je suis devenu français
d'abord dans ma tête dans mon coeur dans
ma manière d'être dans ma langue
j'ai abandonné une grande partie de mon
arménité pour être français il faut le
faire ou alors il faut partir c'est une
définition un peu radicale de ce qu'on
appelle l'assimilation qu'à peu de gens
peut être encore aujourd'hui qui font ce
genre de déclarations je suis devenu
français d'abord enfin il faut
relativiser ça il est devenu français
d'abord mais au moment où ils avaient
il a fallu faire cet effort pour
l'arménie classe arménien et souffrait
il a toujours été là il a donné une
partie de son de son argent pour que
l'arménie puisse à un moment se racheter
de l'électricité à un moment où
l'électricité était coupée en arménie
enfin il n'a jamais abandonné l'arménie
complètement ni un ni lui ni son agent
qui s'appelle even saillant qui a
toujours été très vigilants pour que les
rapports entre la france et l'arménie
puisse permettre à l'arménie de
bénéficier d'un minimum de la diplomatie
française donc oui il est devenu
français d'abord il l'écrivait fortes
forcément très bien et en même temps il
n'a jamais abandonné ses racines
je pense que c'est ça enfin ses droits
l'intégration s'est pas oublié ses
racines
cette volonté d'être d'être français y
compris en disant j'ai abandonné une
partie de ce qu'il était c'est un
presque à un arrachement il était quand
même
il a été élevé en france il était en
france tout petit maintenant la france
être français c'est tout à fait
compatible avec des cultures d origine
étrangère
levinas qui était lui-même naturalisé
français mais philosophe et philosophe
levinas disait que être français on est
français par l'esprit et par le coeur et
je dirais même que l'identité culturelle
française c'est surtout une identité
d'attachement d'amour une identité
philosophique qui peut être ne se montre
jamais aussi belle que quand elle est
incarnée par des gens qui précisément
viennent de l'étranger
dieu sait que oui lui lui a apporté sa
pierre à cette identité française un peu
rapide je peux me permettre que le
fondateur de ce qui est considéré comme
la france était le roi des francs qui
s'appelait clovis parlais pas un mot ni
la taille ni de dialecte local il
parlait saint germain il a abandonné
singer magnitude pour devenir le roi des
francs et le roi des français donc
honnêtement soyons soyons vieille
histoire avec clovis état est un très
bon est un très bon maître en matière
d'abandon d'une partie de soi même tout
en étant respectueux de ce que l'on est
à l'origine et richelieu
la france emmanuel macron ça n'a rien à
voir et être aux antilles ce week-end et
notamment à saint-martin
il a rencontré un certain nombre de
d'habitants dans le quartier d'orléans à
saint-martin dont un ex braqueur qui
avait dû terminer sa peine de prison qui
pose avec le président et un de ses amis
avec des mouvements de doigts que je
vous laisse découvrir à l'antenne
est ce que si choquant est ce que c'est
la photo de trop marine le pen tout de
suite a dit c'est impardonnable a fait
part de son de son indignation
emmanuel macron lui est resté droit dans
ses bottes qu'il a d'ailleurs répondu de
façon directe à la présidente du
rassemblement national lors d'une
conférence de presse écoute et on tirera
rien des discours de haine
et donc ce qui fait que je me suis battu
pour être élu face à marine le pen et
que je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce
que j'aime chaque enfant de la
république quelles que soient ses
bêtises parce que bien souvent parce que
c'est un enfant de la république il n'a
pas choisi l'endroit où il est né il n'a
pas eu la chance de paix alors je peux
le dire il ya une forme voilà il ya une
force de sourire général sur ce plateau
technolo qu'est-ce qui vous amuse c'est
trop c'est trop
phrase est à ses trousses j'aime tout le
monde enfin bientôt il a marché sur
l'eau en finlande à ce stade la veille à
un moment il ya un moment
ces moments où la politique quitte le
critère politique pour devenir de la
psychiatrie est là il faut qu'ils se
calment je comprends qu'il est en
dessous de france on croyait pas que
c'était possible c'est possible il en
dessous de françois hollande
bon d'accord donc là ça n'est pas un
problème ça je suis bien d'accord mais
c'est pas une raison pour embrasser tout
le monde en disant je pardonne tout à
tout le monde et puis j'aime tout le
monde et que donc par conséquent comme
j'aime tout le monde tout le monde va
m'aimer
ces coupes il est président de la
république d il ya des trucs qui est oui
alors là il embrasse les enfants enfin
bon il fait pas il ya ilahi là
il ya un problème maintenant la somme
non mais sans rire c'est embêtant parce
que c'est moi qui vous parle
c'est là où on regrette en fait les
regrette sarkozy chirac
tu vois il ya un truc on a l'impression
que le volant de la voiture lui a
échappé un petit peu il est en train
d'essayer de retrouver
où sont les pédales douces et c'est un
peu embêtant c'est un peu embêtant et je
vois pas où est à travers tout ça pour
parler vraiment sérieusement
où est le discours politique là dedans
voyez non ça vous inquiète aussi sévère
mais je pense que je vais clos lice
avaient réussi à oublier sa jarman
études
je ne provoque lui il oublie sa bande
sont nés des études et donc la ja il ya
un sujet commun il ya un succès il ya
suggéré jeu alors moi je serai moins
sévère que patrick penaud mais cessons
les conditions dans lesquelles ça s'est
passé moitié m'interroge voilà il ya une
averse d'un seul coup il échappe à son
service d'or mais pas aux caméras
filmant le dépôt les équipes de télé
elle arrive à le suivre son service
d'ordre non ce qui est inquiétant son
service d'or d'ailleurs ça m'a amené à
une conclusion c'est que le grand absent
de cette affaire c'est benali s'il avait
été là non on n'en serait pas arrivé là
donc c'est vraiment le grand absent de
cette journée est donc après sur la
photo est sympathique et d'ailleurs on
voit sur cette photo qui lie la chemise
très humide alors qu'il a pris l'averse
et doha ridicule et donc la ville avec
un mec à poil pratiquement mais c'est
son droit mais c'est son devoir on
parlait tout à l'heure vous pisser
on a tous les torts india ou quatre
anglais les lambent président de la
république et que ça c'est une très
belle photo
il envoie ses enfants venaient en masse
je suis en master voilà je pense que je
pense honnêtement que marine le pen
pourrait se passer de ces commentaires
en termes je dirais de projections
imaginaires d'un président de la
république il a cru probablement se
rapprocher du peuple il a cru faire un
geste qui était un geste de grande
proximité et qui tourne un peu au fiasco
parce que l'image projetée n'est pas
conforme ni à la mission qu'il est qui
est la sienne ni même aux dires est
assez à cet écart qu'il a voulu
organiser cet écart qu'ils avouent leur
ai dit il c'est pas du tout le résultat
obtenu
ils voulaient obtenir un écart qui lui
permettent de se rapprocher du peuple
il obtient des cas qui met ces [ __ ]
ridiculiser que de la com
tu ne sais pas où il veut aller
politiquement c'est quoi la ligne
politique de tout ça alors quoi je pense
pas que ce soit fait pour faire pour
émettre une politique c'est le président
de la république la tap
un peuple qui est anxieux qui a été des
quais dépressif qu'il n'y ait plus que
dans une crise sociale majeure
on cherche des identités où on passe le
temps à dire qu'il n'y a plus de
politique à l'heure actuelle on est bon
on a besoin d'un sens politique
il va là bas qui est quand même il a
raison d'y aller parce que c'est un
c'est un département qui a été meurtri
par des catastrophes naturelles
bon ça veut dire quelque chose et la
seule chose qui focalise tous le monde
sait des photos comme ça qui ce qui
ressemble à rien comme ça on n'apprendra
rien disent y avait pas une fois
d'honneur on aurait dit si à rapprocher
est allé voir voilà le doigt d'honneur à
tous mis par terre mais bros mais non
mais on attend un discours politique
on vous pose la question sur twitter est
ce que c'est la photo de trop vous dites
oui mais c'est pas écrasant 61% à le
considérer alors ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'elle veut peut-être dire qu'on
a eu beaucoup d'autres avancent alors
emmanuel macron s'est expliqué sur le
contact de cette photo et notamment
quand dans quelles conditions est ce
qu'il avait rencontré ces deux jeunes
avec lesquels il pose en fait ils
expliquent eux ils lui ont permis de
rencontrer une jeune fille handicapée
qui était un petit peu à distance alors
comme on n'a pas beaucoup entendu cette
séquence
je vous propose de la réécouter ce jeune
dont vous parlez
quelques minutes après on était en bas
au milieu des immeubles il ya une dame
qui est venu me voir et elle m'a dit ma
fille est handicapée et voudrait vous
embrasser elle était très loin
c'était déjà très en retard je pouvais
pas le faire et j'ai pris les deux
jeunes celui qui sortait prison et celui
qui manifestement a fait ce geste crois
que c'est lui qui étend ses apps et lui
fait des études et veut avoir un travail
j'aurais dit aller chercher la petite
île ont porté la petite halle est loin
d' apporter pour que je t'embrasse il
faut arrêter de penser que dans notre
jeunesse parce qu'elle est d'une
certaine couleur ou parce qu'elle a un
moment fait des bêtises il ya rien à
tirer celle inverse
on tirera rien des discours de haine et
donc ce qui fait que je me suis battu
pour être élu face à marine le pen et
que je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce
que j'aime chaque enfant de la
république quelles que soient ses
bêtises parce que bien souvent parce que
c'est un enfant de la république il n'a
pas choisi l'endroit où il est né il n'a
pas eu la chance de pas en faire ça
c'est une île au fon la république il
les aime parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu la
chance de ne pas faire de bêtises
donc en fait maintenant ne pas faire de
bêtises c'est une chance ce n'est pas un
choix
moi je trouve que c'est drôle en fait
c'est tellement grotesque que c'est
drôle mais maintenant si on se calme un
peu et qu'on redevient sérieux
c'est terrifiant cette séquence est
terrifiante ya rien à garder elle
vraiment lll dégouline d'abord de mépris
de mépris envers tout le monde de mépris
en valeur vers ce jeune homme et à qui
il parle comme un enfant alors ton type
est tatoué barbu musclé qui le but
conclut attention mon petit mon petit
monsieur cinéma qu'ils ok oui ni les
briquets non mais franchement
ensuite il est méprisant envers le
peuple qu'ils infantilise complètement
qu'est ce que c'est que cette façon de
parler dit j'aime les enfants la
république c'est quoi ce registre
affectif il nous prend pour des bébés ou
quoi il pense vraiment qu'on a besoin de
quelqu'un d'un nouveau papa c'est très
déresponsabilisant il est méprisant
envers le peuple français aussi parce
que quand il dit il faut arrêter de
penser que parce qu'on ait une certaine
couleur de peau convient dans certains
endroits on ne peut pas réussir que ça
veut dire qu'ils pensent à le peuple
français n'est pas un peuple raciste et
ce n'est pas moi qui dis ce sont les
études les études
test année après année que les français
ne sont pas racistes
or quand évidemment quand macron va
confirmer va sous-entendre que les
français le sont comment voulez vous que
des jeunes qui sont dans des quartiers
dont ils ne sortent pas c'est vrai c'est
la caverne de platon peuvent veulent et
envie d'aller à la rencontre de l'autre
un bien évidemment maquereau en fait le
fait que renforcer leur isolement et
leur sentiment de différence c'est
vraiment consternant et puis surtout il
ya un mépris culturel et un préjugé
culturel d'un racisme épouvantable
qu'est ce que ça veut dire donc en fait
excusez moi quand on est noir quand on
est pauvre
si on ne réussit pas en fait si jamais
il avait réussi en rencontrer un noir
pauvre qui avaient réussi leur ai dit on
on a pas mal j'aurais pas cru
c'est vrai qu'à saint martin la
situation économique et sociale et par
est pas facile non fissile a besoin d'un
disque on va au lit oui on va écouter un
besoin d'un discours qui par exemple
avec qui je vais je vais vous donner
quand même ils entraient d'internautes
en cours pour nourrir le débat c'est un
qui répond à cette question est-ce la
faute aux trop et nous dit ce n'est pas
la photo de trop c'est le président de
trop tonalité assez assez critique sur
sur les réseaux sociaux - christie nous
dit c'est choquant pour un président de
la république
corinne si vous laisser passer cela les
futures générations pourront tous
permettre allusion probablement au doigt
d'honneur fait par là le jeune homme à
côté du président et bastok cet
affligeant ce petit monsieur macron
devient un clown pitoyable une honte
pour sa fonction est ce que le problème
alexander et que ce n'est pas que le
président a du mal à trouver la juste
distance parce que on lui reprocher
d'être trop trop hautains trop loin des
gens donc là peut-être qui fait d il
fait des efforts justement pour se
rapprocher et on le lui reproche encore
ça ne va rien arranger parce qu'il ya un
sentiment plus de deux poids deux
mesures
or qui est incroyable il ya un enfant
qui l'appelle manu il fait un numéro
d'autorité en disant qu'il m'appelle pas
comme ça et c'est un article je suis le
président de la république un
horticulteur lui explique qu'il n'a pas
de travail et lui de traverser la rue et
d'aller chercher du boulot
et là avec lui faire un bras d'honneur
l'ancien braqueur lui fait un bras
d'honneur et il dit que c'est un gamin
bêtise donc il ya deux poids deux
mesures affolant et moi je trouve qu'il
a un réflexe même néocolonial là dessus
parce que ce qui choque les gens si le
doigt d'honneur c'est la vulgarité du
geste a bien sûr fait qu'il soit courir
sur donc là il trahit motion incroyable
le président la république ou alors il
est d'une mauvaise foi incroyable et il
a plus que marine le pen pour pour
exister c'est quand même problématique
politiquement et puis après tout ça
renvoie quand même à la sphère benalla
je pense dans l'inconscient collectif il
ya quand même en tre yassine belattar
alexandre benalla et là on a
l'impression que le président de la
république m s'encanailler avec les
voyous je sais pas si c'est le syndrome
du premier de la classe qui aime bien
être avec le l'élève bagarreur mais il
ya quand même un peu de ça je n'aime pas
faire de la psychologie mais ça fait
penser à ça et encore une fois c'est
problématique pour quelqu'un qui est
censé incarner la nation sera toutefois
il ya quand même aussi un problème
excusez-moi de traitement de
l'information
parce que marine le pen est loin d'être
la seule personne qui s'est insurgé
contre cette séquence aux antilles via
les réseaux sociaux se sont enflammés et
c'est loin c'est pas du tout uniquement
les gens qui sont pro marine le pen ou
d'extrême droite
il ya juste une tradition en france et
je renvoie aux très belles pages là
dessus du livre de patrick buisson la
cause du peuple qui n'est pas cité
souvent mais qui est lu par énormément
de gens sur le fait qu'en france par
tradition depuis toujours le pouvoir est
un garde et non par délégation mais par
incarnation et que c'est justement la
constitution de 1958 et viser
précisément à redonner justement ce
caractère incarné à la fonction
présidentielle et mais depuis en fait
depuis giscard 2
giscard d'estaing mais surtout avec
sarkozy et encore même avec hollande
cette incarnation a disparu alors on
pensait qu'on avait retrouvé cette
incarnation quand macron est élu qu'il a
été prononcé son discours de victoire au
louvre c'était quand même un lieu assez
symbolique puis en fait c'est du en même
temps il ya en même temps il est
présidentielle et en même temps il se
comporte avec une indignité où il n'ya
rien la verticalité la profondeur et la
densité que cette incarnation suppose
oui mais avec le bémol tout de même d'un
monde qui a changé entre le moment on a
rédigé des constate cette reconstitution
58 32 aujourd'hui à partir du moment où
la verticalité de la communication la
verticalité du pouvoir même est remise
en cause par une horizontalité
permanente qui fait que d'ailleurs même
nous qui sommes des commentateurs on est
à la remorque des plus extrêmes sur les
réseaux sociaux belges sont les plus
extrêmes qui sont là sociaux font le
plus de bruit qui très honnêtement je
pense que tout de même
on est alors lui effectivement elle et
il est la caricature de ça qu'il essaye
de suivre les deux voies en même temps
mais il n'est pas le seul je dirais que
le monde aurait dit si tu fais la même
chose et qu'il y aille l'aube allemand
une très grande interrogation de ce
qu'est l'existence d'une démocratie très
verticale qui est celle de la commune de
la constitution de 58 62 avec l'exercice
d'un pouvoir qui se fait rythmé par les
poux les réseaux sociaux a cédé médian
raison c'est vrai ce que ce que vous
dites parce que régulièrement notamment
sur le disco qui l'a fait le 18
septembre sur la santé il a fait
référence aux lois de 58 sur l'hôpital
et en faisant référence à la
constitution de 58 ans on sent que
quelque part il voudrait être
il voudrait incarner le président qui
réforme la vème république réforme la
loi de 58 cents à 60 ans ça a vieilli
faut la changer tout le monde est
d'accord et où il voudrait incarner ça
mais il est tout seul c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas une à 6,6 et enfin il a un
nombre de députés assez conséquent à
l'assemblée nationale mais c'est un
mouvement qui est très gazeux parce
qu'il y en a aucun qui dit la même chose
que l'autre d'accord donc c'est très
gazeux leurs trucs et qu'à voir les
votes c'est toujours un patchwork ça ça
marche pas au sénat c'est totalement
foireux maintenant ça ça ne marche pas
et sur le terrain au niveau des
municipalités dans les régions et dans
les départements
rien bon donc du coup il est quasiment
tout seul il va s'isoler de plus en plus
d'autant que je rejoins ce que dit
caroline
il n'incarne pas maintenant c'est plus
en plus flagrant il n'incarne pas la
fonction et parce que moi je veux bien
qu'on rediscute delà de 50 il y avait le
général de gaulle certaine et la route
le type il avait fait la seconde guerre
mondiale ils savaient ils avaient
analysé les repères qu'il y avait pour
monter une société de la deuxième partie
du xxème siècle qui sortait de l'après
guerre il y avait un sens politique
il faisait passer le sens politique
avant sa carrière là on a l'impression
qu'ils cherchent d'abord à faire passer
son image avant le sens politique
ils se trompent et ça ça ça mais en plus
en exergue quelque chose qui est très
grave c'est qu'un communication d'élise
et n'a pas du tout été réformées elles
s'aggravent
oui avec un bémol encore une fois qui
est que dans 2018 avec un jeune
président qui vient de l'entreprise qui
vient de la banque a été élevé dans une
grande école qui on en apprend un
certain nombre de choses mais peut-être
pas cette verticalité cette autorité
légué par les grands anciens de la
politique s'est fait élire comme vous le
dites par un mouvement gazeux dans un
moment assez horizontal et aujourd'hui
effectivement se trouve confronté lui
même à l'absence de solidité politique
pour pouvoir asseoir son autorité
mais sa volonté de réformer on ne l ai
je dirais rendu indispensable la vème
république on le voit bien
c'est de ce télescopage permanent entre
une autorité voulu par le général de
gaulle et quand je respecte infiniment
et qui aujourd'hui s'interprète avec le
premier tweet qui met par terre la
dernière déclaration de l'homme
politique je pense qu'on est tout de
même à une espèce d'intersection où il
faut bien qu'on se repose la question du
fonctionnement de l'institution veut
dire que le niveau baisse
alex ne fait que ça n'est ce pas un peu
trop sévère avec le président république
parce qu'après tout on reprochait aussi
à françois hollande avoir été ridiculisé
par la gêne leonarda à nicolas sarkozy
de dire casse toi pauvre con ce qui
n'était pas du registre
caroline valentin un peu un peu tout dit
effectivement je pense que nicolas
sarkozy est plus que sur la politique
encore et la déception qu'il engendrait
politiquement a perdu sur l'incarnation
françois hollande n'en parlons même pas
il complètement zappé la sacralité du
pouvoir et c'est vrai que emmanuel
macron s'est autoproclamé jupitérien
donc voilà je fais taire et est
redescendu sur terre et ça ça fait
encore plus mal puisqu'on on en
attendait on en attendait beaucoup donc
je pense pas qu'on soit trop sévère en
plus il aurait pu quand même s'en sortir
mieux que ça là dessus moi ce qui me
gêne c'est pas ton à la limite le de
suite ça peut lui le lui échapper même
s'il a fait beaucoup de photos etc
mais il aurait pu tout simplement dire
elle va effectivement on est dans une
société horizontale je prends des photos
partout j'ai pas vu le doigt d'honneur
j'ai été piégé
au lieu de ça il est dans une espèce de
culture de l'excusé incroyable et il
envoie un message politique qui ait qui
est désastreux donc je pense que
effectivement emmanuel macron est en
train de perdre totalement les pédales
j'allais dire il ya plus de direction à
son à son quinquennat je pense que je
reviens à l affaire banale parce que je
pense que mcqueen été élu sur un grand
malentendu il a été élu sur un désir de
démocratie et de dégage isme et il
incarnait exactement l'inversé tout ce
que les gens refusaient l'europe le
libéralisme la technocratie et jusqu ici
l arrivée à maquiller salle derrière sa
jeunesse derrière une communication
dynamique mais à partir du moment où il
ya eu affaire banale à bas toute cette
paille est et c'est cette illusion s'est
dissipée et le roi est nu et je crois
que c'est ce qui explique son désarroi
actuel n'arrive plus à avoir il a été
élu parce qu'elle canard enchaîné voilà
alors colite sur une fine fé total et
une droite cas pas su rebondir parce que
je peux te dire que fin décembre la
droite aurait dit on enlève fillon mais
juppé jupes étaient présentes à un
faible taux présidentielle car le temps
nous manque pour ça et comme la tonalité
sur ce plateau est assez critique je
crois qu'on peut le dire vidal et du
président de la république de nuances
au fait que xavier couture dont
l'équanimité n'est plus à prouver
2 commentaires de véronique qui nuance
je pense juste qu'il n'a pas vu ce geste
d'un petit voyou et c'est également
l'avis de hall qui nous dit le doigt
d'honneur de l'homme est déplacé mais
macron n'est pas responsable et il n'a
rien vu les jeunes ces macro pendant ce
temps valérie pécresse était hier
l'invité du grand jury rtl le figaro lci
avec un ton assez martial on dirait
aujourd'hui assez régaliens parmi les
propositions
voici celle ci qui jouit d'un nous a
assez étonné qu'ils interviewent
écoutons la présidente de la région ile
de france
moi je suis pour le doublement des
peines pour les crimes commis dans les
quartiers les plus criminogènes et vous
risquez la stigmatisation mais c'était
pas de la stigmatisation
c'est quand même dingue que dans
certains quartiers dans certains
départements de france lle beaucoup plus
de crimes est beaucoup moins de
sanctions si je peux me permettre un
acte véniel à guéret sera aussi aux
tempes unique un acte grave à bobigny
alors le débat déjà commencé patrick
collot c'est ridicule
enfin l injustice nous sommes dans un
pays le droit est le même pour tout le
monde vous n'allez pas commencer à
définir un droit qui d'un côté d'un
trottoir sera celui-là puis si tu
traverses la rue pour reprendre cette
phrase célèbre maintenant ça serait une
autre sanction c'est que c'est
complètement enfin c'est remettre en
cause la lucidité des des juges puis
alors partie comme elle est partie à ce
moment là il peut revenir sur le droit
de la défense aussi peut dire quelqu'un
qui a fait commis un crime dans ces
zones là il ya plus de défense il ya
plus rien enfin non je ne comprends pas
cette classe politique qui va chercher
des espèces de solutions totalement
ridicule qu'elle dise qu'il faut que les
peines qui sont infligées à ces voyous à
ces criminels soit appliquée ça on
comprendrait parce qu'en effet il ya une
partie des peines qui sont pas
appliquées c'est là notre problème
d'accord bon voilà ça ça on comprendrait
mais de dire d'un coup qui va y avoir
des quartiers qui vont être plus
sanctionnés que d'autres mais enfin
c'est totalement ridicule alors j'ajoute
ya pas la route
j'ajoute qu'elle a précisé que ça
existait déjà au danemark que ça
marchait assez bien j'avoue que j'ai pas
eu le temps de vérifier ce qu'il en
était de cette expérience
et puis frédéric péchenard qui connaît
un peu ce sujet puisque c'est l'ancien
patron de la police nationale
mais ce qui est c'est vrai qui est
aujourd'hui l'un des vice-présidents de
valérie pécresse à la région
ile-de-france mais soutient plutôt le
l'initiative de valérie pécresse en
disant deux arguments que je vous livre
le premier c'est de dire mais cette
différenciation de traitement existent
déjà par exemple quand vous portez
atteinte à l'intégrité physique d'un
policier
et bien c'est plus lourdement sanctionné
par la loi que quand c'est une personne
et puis le deuxième élément que frédéric
péchenard mettait en avant pour
justifier la proposition de valérie
pécresse était de dire il ya des
banlieues qui sont des espèces de
châteaufort jeu je cite sa phrase des
sanctuaires dans lesquelles personne ne
peut entrer et que si on tape un peu
plus fort dans ces quartiers là ce
serait pas plus mal alexandre avec you
will peut alors que plusieurs choses je
pense qu'ils seraient immédiatement
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
parce que jusqu'à preuve de contraire la
république est une et indivisible donc
il ya une forme d'amateurisme chez
valérie pécresse
effectivement alors elle le sait parce
que j'ai quand même maître des requêtes
au conseil d'état considère dematic ça
veut dire on fait de la démagogie 1 voit
bien que son créneau qui était plutôt en
macro nisme de droite n'est plus très
porteur en ce moment qu'il faut quatre
jours six le tour et elle fait une
proposition mais qui a une proposition
absurde
ceci dit elles s'inspirent effectivement
de tout un péquin package de loi qui a
été passée au danemark qui s'appelait un
danemark 100 sociétés parallèles sans
ghetto effectivement cette mesure est
passé mais ça s'accompagnait de tout un
autre de beaucoup d'autres mesures qui
me paraissent plus plus plus
intéressantes par exemple limiter à 30%
dans les collèges et les lycées la
proportion d'enfants d'immigrés
empêcher les gens qui ont été condamnés
de revenir dans leur quartier ça je
pense que c'est que c'est pas idiot à
les faire aller très fort sur
l'assimilation en doublement n'oblige
les enfants d'étrangers à mettre leurs
enfants à la crèche dès lors un an donc
ça ça va s'accompagner d'un ensemble
d'un ensemble cohérent et ce n'était pas
une mesure comme sa symbolique vont dire
qu'il ya un problème de société
parallèle dans certains quartiers oui
surtout dans le land dans la région
qu'elle dirige c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important mais je crois
que ça doit s'accompagner d'une
réflexion de fond est que là elle a
simplement voulu faire une proposition
choc pour récupérer un peu de
l'électorat de droite
je vous livre les commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux d'abord sur twitter où
nous vous posons la question faut-il
doubler les peines dans certaines
banlieues comme le préconisait ce
dimanche valérie pécresse
oui 52% non 48% cédant peut être un
petit peu plus partagée que sur ce
plateau encore kg 1 deux invités qui
n'ont pas qu'il se soit encore ici même
pour les récidivistes à l'avion les
rails on est durcie d'appliquer les
peines
le problème c'est l'application des
peines et quand on dit ça la justice la
justice y 10 bat donnez nous les moyens
notamment les bracelets électroniques
les contrôles des dates de l'application
des peines des juges d'application des
peines et ses tenues aux moyens et puis
tu te revois à la police la police qui
va donner les moyens notamment pour
aller dans les quartiers difficiles et
c'est pour remettre la république et le
droit dans ces quartiers tout mais voilà
mais on est on est sur un système qui se
mord la queue en disant vas là et puis
d'un autre côté talent budget qui
arrivent en disant eh ben on comprime le
budget de la justice on comprime le
budget de la police fait mieux avec moi
ça c'est impossible surtout pour la
sécurité et on perd dans la sécurité
vous avez vous qu'à voir le nombre de
crimes qui sont annoncés régulièrement
et en ce moment c'est quelque chose qui
pose problème
on va écouter le pagne sus de xavier
couture mais avant je vous livre cette
réflexion de linda qui me paraît plein
de plein de bon sens avant de doubler
les peines il faudrait déjà qu'il fasse
la première voilà c'est ça avant
d'envisager une autre aviez couture mais
moi je partage tout ce qui a été dit et
on est vraiment aux confins de l'absurde
sur la chose elle même simplement la
proposition du pour mission laquelle
elle ne croit pas elle même évidemment
c'est ce que c'est la politique de la
moule est à dire le torero se cache
derrière
punchy fond rouge dans lequel il
faudrait qu'on essaie on n'aime pas
foncez c'est pas du tout le sujet le
sujet c'est qu'effectivement il y à des
châteaux forts
il y a des quartiers dans lesquels la
police a du mal à entrer et il y a par
ailleurs un engorgement d'un certain
nombre de tribunaux et particulièrement
en seine-saint-denis dont on sait que
les moyens sont insuffisants pour tt
d'entendre des boîtiers qui sont à
traiter une fois qu'on a dit ça il faut
que la république fasse son boulot elle
a un arsenal juridique qui est largement
suffisant pour traiter l'ensemble de ces
problématiques
simplement il faut effectivement
prononcé des peines arrêter les suspects
prononcer les peines et les faire
appliquer c'est tout ce qui a été dit
j'ajouterai quand même que dans cette
affaire on a l'impression qu'elle a
amassé une feuille de photocopies
froissé nature inapplicable dans la
corbeille de wauquiez et elle se dit
puisque j'ai un petit problème avec
macron mais que ça marche moins bien mon
mac ronis mme de droite je vais aller
faire du voyeurisme de gauche à des
blocs charisme en plein d'eau c'est
vraiment des indices ou c'est vraiment
une population absurde dont la portée
n'est que politique et donc ne traite
pas du tout le sujet sur lequel elle
s'est exprimée
la cible c'est pas la justice et
l'application des peines
la cible c'est évoquer ou maquereau
franchement c'est un digne d'elle voilà
une réaction de stéphane troussel qui
est le président socialiste du
département de seine-saint-denis c'est
votre réaction qui lui faisait penser
xavier couture lui refuse qui serait à
ses yeux une justice d'exception en
expliquant en affirmant que cette mesure
serait à la fois inefficace et
anti-républicaine
karl valentin avez vous envie de
défendre valérie pécresse qui plutôt
critiqué sur ce plateau jusque après je
savais pas y arriver je ne vais pas y
arriver je suis atterré en fait je suis
atterré pu le début de l'émission
exactement je suis atterré par le piètre
au niveau de cette femme politique est
quand même là depuis très longtemps qui
est très bien formés et qui devrait être
un peu plus sérieuse que ça alors pour
revenir déjà sur ce qui était assez
marrant en fait c'est qu'elle disait de
manière assez naïve
il faut faire ce type de mesures sinon
l'extrême droite a monté en fait son
objectif c'est pas vos pieds et c'est
papa course et l'extrême droite
elle voit
c'est passe ailleurs en europe et elle a
bien compris que pour contrer la montée
des populismes jeu mais les guillemets
de chantal delsol à ce mot qui est
forcément péjoratif il fallait soit
faire une coalition gouvernementale avec
up mais elle veut pas se faire une
position gouvernementale avec marine le
pen soit il faut récupérer leurs
propositions et leurs solutions
ce qui est un peu dommage c'est que
effectivement dans le package elle a
pris la seule proposition la seule
mesure des danois qui est la plus
contestée et même là bas c'était
contraire à la constitution du danemark
en tout cas c'est compliqué c'est
contraire à la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme et ça peut poser
un gros problème de contradiction avec
la convention de l'onu sur la
discrimination raciale
surtout au-delà de tout cela le problème
que cela pose
et ça c'est un c'était une remarque est
une critique qui s'applique aussi aux
mesures qui ont été prises au danemark
qui ont sont assez récentes donc on n'a
pas la conséquence le résultat de ces
mesures
ce sont des mesures qui ne prennent pas
du tout en compte la culture et la
religion de ses populations
or c'est la culture tribale de ces
populations la religion musulmane et
surtout la montée de l'islamisme dans
ces populations qui crée le ferment qui
ferment ces populations contre les
populations du pays d'accueil
si vous prévoyez des mesures qui ne vise
que ces populations
vous justifiez vous en faites vous
donner plus de force aux discours de ces
imams et de ses autres émissaires de
l'islam politique qui radicalise les
jeunes en leur disant croire en leur
disant la population majoritaire veau
rejette elle est raciste elle ne veut
pas de vous exhorter mans la caverne de
platon je parlais tout à l'heure et
notre travail à nous en fait pour lutter
contre cet islamisme c'est aussi de
rééduquer ces jeunes et de leur dire
venez on vous attend on n'a rien contre
vous y'a pas de problème
venez la seule chose qu'on le demande de
vous c'est que vous respectiez nos
traditions notre culture qui est fondée
sur nos principes républicains en france
liberté égalité fraternité
complètement d'accord à tripoli et je
joue coupe un peu la parole pardonnez
moi pour qu'on parle d'acte un quatrième
sujet même brièvement
c'est aujourd'hui la journée
internationale des personnes âgées c'est
plutôt l'occasion de s'arrêter quelques
minutes pour répondre à cette question
très simple
prenons nous à ses soins
nos aînés il ya un sondage intéressant
qui a été réalisée par le crédoc qui est
publié aujourd'hui où on interroge les
français de plus de 35 ans donc c'est
pas uniquement les seniors comme on dit
aujourd'hui et qui disent ben oui si
j'étais amené à rejoindre une structure
d'accueil pour personnes âgées une
maison de retraite un ehpad
ce serait d'abord pour pour soulager mes
proches et en même temps les gens sont
lucides ils disent
bien sûr on les je les verrai - je me
couperais aussi delà de la société et en
même temps on sait que la façon de vivre
aujourd'hui fait qu'on peut
difficilement faire ce qu'on faisait
encore il ya un siècle c'est-à-dire
d'accueillir ses vieux parents chez soi
patrick peloux s'éteint c'est difficile
de trouver la bonne la bonne réponse à
cette question j'ai combien d'heures
vous avez trois minutes une minute une
minute là non il ya plein de choses
justes sur votre saut sur ce qu'ils
veulent ce que vous dites là déjà va
voir ses proches de moins en moins
bonnes conditions c'est premièrement le
problème du logement c'est qu'en effet
vous avez raison on est on a quitté la
société définitivement du xxème siècle
pour les personnes âgées ne pouvait plus
les garder surtout qu'ils visent de plus
en plus avec des polypathologies des
polyhandicap mais la deuxième question
se mettre en retrait de la société 62%
c'est la grande interpellation qui à
l'heure actuelle sur l'évolution
d'alzheimer ou plus vous vous retirez de
la société et plus vous risquez d'avoir
c'est là où il ya un débat à l'heure
actuelle qui à mon avis est insuffisant
mais qui est vraiment un débat très
intéressant pour savoir si la maladie
d'alzheimer est vraiment véritablement
une maladie somatiques de dégénérescence
neurologique
c'est un fait et c'est ce qu'on voit sur
sur les scanners les irm mais aussi une
adéquation entre le compte de
l'environnement socio-économique de la
personnes âgées
donc on est vraiment avec des
problématiques énorme on a fait un
sondage concernant les ehpad
il ya eu un reportage récemment dans une
sur une chaîne de télé montrant sur
france 2 contre huk dans quelles
conditions ils travaillent dans les
ehpad
moi je suis c'est atterrant c'est s'il
fallait un curseur sur le niveau de
l'humanisme en france c'est pas la prise
en charge de la petite enfance qui est
remarquablement pris en charge
c'est les personnes âgées c'est le
polyhandicap c'est le balad polier voilà
c'est en même temps que ça des coutures
on a une responsabilité nous la société
au global parce que c'est aussi
peut-être parce qu'on s'occupe mois des
deux de ses anciens que ne le faisait
les générations précédentes je crois
qu'effectivement le vieillissement de la
population j'ai vu le reportage sur sur
les ehpad qui était à la fois terrible
et outranciers c'est à dire qu'en fait
ils renvoient l'ensemble des
téléspectateurs à leur propre
culpabilité
que faisons-nous nous-mêmes vis-à-vis de
nos anciens parce qu'à la réalité quand
on s'approche les ehpad et moi je
connais bien les légendes orpea qui ont
été mises en cause est qui et qui font
un travail qui est leur travail alors il
ya bien sûr à la marche des choses qui
sont montrable et de manière difficile
dans une émission mais la réalité elle
c'est pas celle là
la réalité c'est quelle est la durée de
vie d'un ancien qui entrent dans un
ehpad
personne ne fait cette statistique alors
effectivement il y à un décrochage de la
société qui ne donne pas envie de vivre
c'est ça le vrai problème est donc on
est dans une société où nous mêmes nous
tous qui avons des anciens devant nous
je vais en devenir à bientôt
on doit s'interroger sur la manière dont
on les traite à titre individuel nous
mêmes les structures familiales
on a un peu explosé le 20e siècle est
passé le 21e arrive avec ses grandes
avancées horizontale numériques et
autres mais au passage il ya un certain
nombre de pans de l'humanité qui sont
abandonnés au bord de la route et les
vieux sont aux premières loges de cet
abandon
je crois que ça n'est pas en remettant
en cause un meilleur dans les ehpad
fonctionne consorts qu'on résoudra le
problème et je salue l'initiative de la
ministre
agnès buzyn qui lance une grande
consultation sur le sujet qu'il a
annoncé aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'effectivement sur une grande
consultation nationale on pourra
peut-être faire émerger quelques
quelques points
l'amélioration du traitement collectif
qu'on donne à nos anciens pardonnez moi
c'est bien beau ce qu'elle a
on se brisa mais il ya déjà six rapports
qui disent tous la même chose le conseil
économique et social et environnemental
a fait un rapport récemment en disant on
est le nombre de personnes qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées
dépendantes dans les ehpad
on est deux fois moins nombreux qu'en
allemagne par exemple
donc qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour créer
des emplois puisque nous avons
énormément de chômeurs de créer des
emplois de recréer du lien de recréer de
la rééducation des personnes âgées etc
il ya tout ça il ne s'agit pas de
montrer du doigt tel ou tel organisme
multinationales parce que c'est le cas
aussi parce qu'ils appellent ça c'est
une réalité lors grille parce que ça
rapporte du pognon
d'accord mais qu'est ce qu'on fait quand
vous avez des familles qui doivent payer
4000 à 6000 euros par mois pour garder
la personne âgée dépendante dans une
institution parce qu'ils peuvent plus
faire c'est une réalité sociale les
personnes qui peuvent payer actuellement
c'est des gens qui sont propriétaires
qui ont connu le plein emploi etc
ça sera pas le cas dans 20 ans siège au
caire ce que je crains c'est que je sais
c'est qu'on est en train de faire naître
une nouvelle pauvreté les gréements et
tu vends ta mère c'est patrick pleau
deux commentaires de nos internautes au
port au rôle qui le dit les la relation
avec les aînés fait partie de notre
culture
en chine on prend mieux soin des aînés
et ignorants qui ajoutent ils sont
ignorés alexandre ii vecchio un point de
vue sur ce sujet question une question
compliquée parce que je crois que d'un
côté effectivement
peut-être qu'il ya une forme d'égoïsme
de la société qui avait pas autrefois et
de l'autre côté on est quand même face à
des pathologies nouvelles quand
quelqu'un alzheimer c'est quand même
très difficile de le garder chez soi au
bout d'un certain stade
donc là on va avoir besoin je crois de
deux acteurs majeurs de français qui
sont d'un côté la société les familles
les structures les structures familiales
et de l'autre de l'autre l'état or
malheureusement le modèle qu'on fuit de
plus en plus depuis les années ça a pas
l'air de s'arranger c'est plutôt la
philosophie du gouvernement actuel c'est
celle de l'atomisation de la société de
l'individu roi et donc si on continue à
prendre ce chemin là effectivement on va
aller dans le mur puisque dans quelques
années on va être confronté à un
problème sanitaire social d'ampleur
majeur donc c'est vraiment à un
changement de paradigme et de
philosophie politique je crois qu'il
faut entreprendre dès maintenant pour
résoudre pour avoir une chance de
résoudre ce problème de main karl
valentin il nous reste quelques instants
pour conclure et c'est vaut-il l'état
les amis certes mais il ne faut pas
oublier les actionnaires donc je vous
renvoie à un numéro d'envoyé spécial qui
était diffusée l'an dernier et qui
parlait de deux actionnaires du réseau d
pad smr les opalines qui ont 64 ehpad et
qui en vingt ans se sont hissés aux
inventions cinquième de 305 euros les
plus grosses fortunes de france
donc on n'a pas assez large en dessous
mais enfin c'est un jour va
manifestement quelque part et j'espère
que dans le loir le grand rapport
d'agnès visant ce point sera adressé
merci beaucoup merci a tous les atouts
le point de vue s'étirer pour ce soir et
puis on se quitte avec la bohème une des
chansons préférées de charles aznavour
bonsoir que les moindres
ne peuvent pas connaître mon apprend ce
temps là
à accrocher des lilas jusque sous nos
fenêtres
et si l'humble garni qui nous servait ni
ne payait pas de mine
c'est là qu'on s'est connu moi qui
criait famine et toi qui posait
[Musique]
on la boit ça voulait dire